plutôt que d'offrir des cadeaux qui
parfois ne plaisent pas vraiment grande
tendance cette année les chèques cadeaux
début des années 2000 un petit nouveau
fait son apparition en france
le chèque cadeau il apparaît alors comme
une réelle alternative aux cadeaux
traditionnels
si vous êtes pressés ou en panne
d'imagination c'est la solution idéale à
la proche des fêtes de fin d'année ma
soeur ça va quand même acheter donc je
lui ai dit mais autant que l'offre
d'achat copa do comme ça je savais quoi
faire
et voilà le chèque cadeau un achat
pratique avant tout parfumerie vêtements
livres ou encore jeux vidéo
il s'utilise partout à n'importe quel
moment
mais ce nouveau moyen d'achat n'a pas
que des adeptes certains le trouvent un
personnel en témoigne cette femme en
à quelques jours de noël c'est ado un
peu vite fait c'est à dire que moi
j'aime bien le chercher un petit peu me
creuser la tête pour savoir ce qui
ferait plaisir à la personne chez cadeau
et c'est un petit peu le cadeau passe
partout
pas de recherche vraiment mais la
véritable star des cadeaux
dématérialisés
c'est le coffret cadeau qui apparaît
aussi au milieu des années 2000 je
savais pas trop trop quoi choisir au
début voitures de sport et ses
éclairages je me suis dit que
l'hélicoptère c'est quand même un petit
peu plus particulier et voilà j'ai
téléphoné j'ai pris rendez vous cet
acheteur a trouvé son bonheur
ce n'est pas le cas de cette femme en
2008 corinne achète un coffret séjour
utilisable jusqu'à la fin de l'année
mais la mère de famille se voit dans
l'impossibilité d'en profiter au mois
d'août j'ai demander n'importe quel
week-end jusqu'au 31 décembre tous les
hôtels étaient complets donc aucun
samedi deux disponibles d'ici le 31
décembre qui fait que je ne peux pas
partir à l'hôtel et mon coffret ne sert
à rien face à ces critiques
des améliorations ont été apportées par
exemple la durée de validité a été
augmenté à 3 ans en tout cas le marché
du coffret cadeau se porte bien en
france
il est dominé par une entreprise
française ou ander box qu'en plus d'être
implanté dans 11 pays
la marque a généré un chiffre d'affaires
de 250 millions d'euros en 2019
[Musique]